yeah i think uh let me let me find it
here i i had it
i'll say that that would be there it is
all right pete davidson pete davidson
was uh was doing a um was doing an
interview with charlemagne the god
apparently he does interviews now i
honestly who i don't hate
he's actually yeah he's
he's been kind of i don't know
he's got balls sometimes okay well let's
check it out this uh i have a couple
time stamps
like people are like hey my friends will
tell me now we're at a point where like
people will come over and be like hey
you gotta [ __ ] we're all [ __ ]
pissed and terrified so you're not
pissed but like we're all like worried
so you should go
i got i got a good group around me where
then they give a [ __ ] what does cutting
look like
i was talking about cutting himself oh
good start my chest uh that's so i
that's is he a girl
yeah you [ __ ] girl
stuff yeah i started getting tats uh all
my chests to like cover them on your
justices
yeah bro he's black now
do you notice how much more hood he
talks when she's talking to charlemagne
super hood around black people it's very
funny it's comical uh it's just like a
release it's just something that like uh
it's if you can't get a tattoo or like
if you can't it's never in like any like
spot
that's like uh serious it's just like
it's
whenever you're so manic and upset i
hate him i'm sorry
royce last night sent this to me for
prep
and then he just i just was like i had
to write it over and over again i was
like i hate him yeah i hate him so much
i hate him i'm trying to watch this but
i hate him he's
everything about him is he's so hateable
right
on every core
like is it honest question is there
anything pete davidson could do do you
think to turn you around on him
one thing what i can't say it
that's not
[Laughter]
but seriously is it really when you
think about it
no no he's already
to me the the being an snl cast member
and pretending you're a rock star thing
is still cringe and he's just
i don't think he can undouche himself
enough to ever be redeemed
i think that would work for me but now i
like you go to rehab you learn like oh
you could like take a cold shower you
could work out you could listen to music
really loud you work out
you could read this excerpt you could go
on the comm app you can call a friend
you can wait five minutes there's just
you know so much [ __ ] you learn
that is like into your brain if you get
to do some of that stuff so like um you
know that's how i've been taking care of
it did the cutting bring any relief you
think that uh lauren michaels likes that
not only does he have
tattoos on his hands but on his neck and
on his behind his ear because he loves
to be when you're playing characters you
want to be able to have tattoos on your
neck and ears well yeah no he looks it
just didn't stop phil hartman i mean you
guys you never remember phil hartman was
like he had a face tattoo yeah he did
damage
the damage right here yeah i mean it was
embarrassing but no of course not that's
why they loved guys like phil hartman
because that guy came in and was like
everybody who are you turning me into
today
is it even a white person you know what
i mean like and it was no worry about
like oh i'm coming in man all [ __ ] up
dude it was like good morning
good morning everyone
looking forward to tonight
boy i love my wife but
nothing's ever gonna work everything at
home is just okay nothing's ever gonna
seriously like it was amazing but this
is yeah a guy coming yeah
what is oh cool pete in addition to uh
all of the tattoos where what is this
bandage
i was cutting last night i was sad
because my pop star girlfriend left me
like can you imagine like wouldn't you
be like this is what i gotta [ __ ]
deal with this guy yeah lauren has to
write just a bunch of breaking bad skits
just to fit him in
just we'll make him skinny pete yeah
like oh yeah it's awesome well it's i
mean you know so it's not awesome no
it's not it's it's not awesome but like
the feeling of it after is just your you
feel really stupid after but like as
you're doing it it feels really great
he's dude he's twisted we've all had
girlfriends like this right yes
it's like getting tagged
okay so you think that you're trying to
match
i guess physical pain with emotional
yeah when i'm really angry and upset it
feels really good to just get like
needled up or get a tad or like or like
i don't know handling emotions like an
adult maybe yeah that would be cool i i
think that would be you think so cool if
you if you wanted to do something like
that
oh [ __ ] like that i need you to get in
the boxing feet i know everybody's
saying that i gotta quit the cigs first
hey mike
you know what he calls them
he calls them the sigs
gotta quit the cigs first bro
i'm sorry i can't oh we got more i can't
do this
this is right this is bad this is like
okay well i'm gonna i think you're
really gonna like this coming up part i
can't but i gotta click the cigs though
bro you'll love this here we go it's
just awful
now you you got a joke and you're
special you're netflix special yeah but
well i don't even know if it's a joke
but it's called louis ck yes sir
and he's supposedly trying to get you
fired from snl for smoking
too much weed yes is was that a real
story yes it's a true story uh i don't
want to like ruin the joke but pretty
much like he just like ratted me out to
my boss yeah it was so weird
i never really got over that was it
personally why
so you're mad at louis ck probably
because instead of because louis ck was
a writer for snl for a long time so
instead of like paying attention and
providing this because here's what
happened this is
he's a [ __ ] little worm right
here's what probably happened
everybody on snl did drugs okay let's
not pretend that david probably still
does david spade chris farley they all
did drugs
but i'm going to assuming this is just
an assumption that they did their drugs
but they were sitting there at the table
reads going what are we doing next hey
you know what i have a really hey you
know what what if we got like chris
farley and patrick swayze to do a
chippendales thing that would be
hilarious the problem is pete seeing as
you like a woman and you were cutting
yourself you were probably sad and you
were probably outside smoking weed
instead of helping provide for the show
i'm really surprised you're not there a
lot yeah you know what i mean whereas
like you said there's people that just
did their drugs in the [ __ ] building
exactly just came in and we're like all
right what are we doing what do we got
we're here we're doing it um he's doing
like you just said he wants to be the
rock star yeah but also be at snl and
it's like then that means you're doing
the the whole showing up late thing and
being cool guy and that's just louis ck
worked with when he was a writer louis
ck worked with a lot of people that did
drugs
yeah
maybe it's because
you smoked a lot of weed and you were
insufferable yeah like you smoke a lot
of weed or was it when he was guest
hosting maybe when he was guest hosting
because louis ck wasn't a writer one no
davidson was there so probably when he
was guest hosted yeah
but he probably was just because louie
is borderline autistic and louis was
probably just sharing his opinion or
reflecting on pete davidson in front of
him or to lauren or so like like you
know i could imagine you being like you
know this [ __ ] guy he's a mess
is was that a real story yes it's a true
story uh i don't want to like ruin the
joke but pretty much like he just like
ratted me out to my boss yeah it was so
weird
i never really got over that
although you've gone to rehab several
times so clearly you do have an
addiction problem don't forget weed for
a second but still you do you have an
addiction problem and then somebody
pointed out that you may have an
addiction problem and they're the bad
guy was it personally vindicating i
think for you to see his comedic
downfall oh my god
it was amazing
it was amazing look at him rubbing his
hands while he does it yeah i imagine
it's what like ariana feels like now
like just watching me just tumble for
two years no i don't think i don't i
i
don't
first off his hair is so mean but i
don't think she cares dude first off
charlemagne
uh
louis ck didn't have a comedic downfall
he's still as funny as he ever was yeah
watch his stand up he's still as funny
as he ever was yeah you just you woke
frags yeah you [ __ ] you ruined his
life which is something that's
completely different he didn't just
become bad at comedy
you know he wasn't making a [ __ ]
national lampoons reboot or something he
was
just
[ __ ] dragged across the coals because
he asked girls to jerk off in front of
him and they said yes
just being like yes
yeah i'm sure it's very vindicating but
yeah it felt great i loved it that guy
hasn't been nice to many people so
really
yeah he's not a nice guy well the thing
is if something bad happens to someone
and they're a nice guy like people
[ __ ] don't stop talking to you and
your friends don't okay so that's why uh
nobody likes you pete because you're not
a nice guy so let's start that you make
people [ __ ] sign and a million dollar
ndas to go see your [ __ ] stand up you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] piece
of garbage you're not a nice guy you're
a [ __ ] phony you don't even care
about yourself this guy's a photo yeah
by the way the other thing [ __ ] maybe
you know what louis ck might not be a
nice guy
i
don't
really hear a lot
for or against him yeah but maybe he is
maybe he isn't but the thing is is that
there's something that louis ck is
that you'll never be
which is good at comedy see that's you
no matter how much you tumble
you're [ __ ] dating
[ __ ] 18 year old pop stars i that's
great it's probably awesome i've never
laughed at anything pete davidson has
ever done ever the only thing i've ever
laughed about in pete davidson's life
was what happened to his dad on 9
11. besides that there's been nothing
that i've laughed about he's yeah i look
man he's been a disaster he's
never been funny piece of [ __ ] i only
remember him
really was he was one of opie's little
pet projects yeah yeah opie kept
bringing them on but it was like
ugh like he was just i don't know yeah
he's just kind of like
stat i want to say long island trash but
it was from staten island but still
staten island trash is
very similar to long island trash like
he's doing shows in [ __ ] israel he
had to leave the country you know what i
mean like as he's still here people
still here not that aziz did
he
he
he he he just did skankfest
yeah half of water you know but
wait wait wait so you're saying not to
disease so you're defending aziz though
because aziz was nice to you so you just
base all your relationships on whether
he was nice to you yeah
have you ever thought that maybe you
were the [ __ ] in these situations
have you ever thought that maybe you
were the problem there pd boy
um yeah that dude's just a piece of [ __ ]
really yeah he's not nice maybe he's
changed i don't know but like he's not
nice to young comics no he wasn't nice
to you
he wasn't nice to you because i've
actually heard stories of other comics
that say p that louis was really nice
he's not nice to young comics are you
[ __ ] kidding me did you watch his tv
show louie you could say what you want
about louie that's a loyal dude every
comic who's ever done anything with
louie was on that show watch louie
every comic every [ __ ] joe derosa
bobby kelly he threw a lot of people in
his shows that were not even good dane
cook stole jokes from him and he had him
on his show yeah he gave people doug
stanhope
people doug stanhope by the way is a
fringe i love stanhope but he's not a
[ __ ] he's a guy who shows him [ __ ]
utahns nobody needs him on a tv show and
which by the way stand up on louis was
great that was one of the best episodes
[ __ ] jim norton nick de paulo when
nick depaolo was even mr conservative
guy he had him on don't [ __ ] pretend
that louie isn't loyal to his friends
maybe just maybe he didn't help you out
because you're a piece of trash to say
that louis doesn't take care of his
friends is not good to young comics is
[ __ ] [ __ ] louie has been nothing
but nice to people in the [ __ ]
industry sarah silverman sarah silverman
defended louis ck after the jerking off
thing and she's a woke sjw idiot you
know and pete too he's got a problem
like where he's he's got to learn some
humility because like
look even i
at times in my life thought oh well this
guy kind of sucks because they weren't
cool to me or this guy's and then you
look kind of look back and you go well i
was also kind of a punk right he needs
to learn in his life that he can be a
he's a punk and he needs to stop being a
punk because you could rub people the
wrong way and then you go well he's not
nice to young comics well maybe he
rubbed him the wrong way and then maybe
he didn't like you like that's is he not
allowed to do that andrew jackson's got
a good point i'm outraged how dare
someone be mean to a drug addicted
self-absorbed cutting garbage person
like pete davidson yeah yeah but you see
do you understand my point like
if if if i'm like a legend in some
business and somebody comes up to me but
they're snot-nosed punk and they're
smoking weed and they're being
disrespectful to me
but then i'm like well all right and
then i don't really help this person or
do give a [ __ ] about them and then years
later you hear him go like oh he doesn't
do enough to help young comic what do i
owe
any person if i don't like you you know
what i mean yeah i know that's a very
good point like if i don't like somebody
like
i'm sure there's plenty of people louie
likes that'll tell you yeah he put me on
he put me on shows he did this with me
gave me a gig here
like he's helped dudes out that he likes
but what the [ __ ] is this yo [ __ ] him
he's a piece of [ __ ] he doesn't help you
on comics no he doesn't help anybody in
your little camp because he probably
doesn't like you
it's life
at one point you wanted to get a tattoo
of him though did i yeah should i really
yeah well the reason wasn't a good
reason what was the reason because you
said that you got a harry potter tattoo
and you say the next day alan rickman
the guy who played snape died then you
got a willy wonka oh yeah oh yeah and i
said i wanted to get a louis tattoo
because all those guys died after i got
the tattoo yeah you said you got a willy
wonka tattoo
your dad died in 9 11. yeah uh all those
guys died up
let me tell you i already did just this
interview i wouldn't want to help you
not that i could or anyway i'm the
norman nobody but
who would want to help this dude out
who would want to help the
look at you who would want to help you
who would want to help your career pete
who
who in their right mind
first off would somebody with all of
these [ __ ] problems and all these
[ __ ] addiction things he keeps going
back to rehab and he keeps cutting
himself why would you what let's say
you're louis ck why would you invest
your time which is valuable
into somebody that's like this is going
to self-destruct why would you invest
your time and again he doesn't have to
but you're right
to being a comic doesn't mean you have
to help other comics
that's that's not a prerequisite of
being a good comic like here's what i'm
going to guess happened
is that he was probably late to
something maybe a rehearsal the day
before something and he probably came in
smelling like weed
looking and sounding the way pete
davidson does
and and louie probably said like is this
what's what's this guy what's his
[ __ ] deal and that's because he's a
[ __ ] mess good point sloth and worst
of all pete's not funny yeah yeah that's
that that's that's the biggest the
greatest sin you could that's the
biggest sin right there pete you're not
a funny guy you're not an entertaining
dude by the way you don't have to i mean
you should be funny if you're on a
[ __ ] comedy show but you're not even
charming
you're not even
there's nothing about you're not even a
hard worker
like you know chris kattan wasn't the
funniest guy but chris kattan [ __ ]
showed up he was during every skit
whatever humility whatever you want man
i got you people don't want to help you
you know why people louie didn't want to
help you pete people don't want to help
you because you don't help yourself
why would somebody help you
if you don't even help yourself if
you're still cutting yourself like a 15
year old girl but dude you don't get it
man it's like it makes you feel alive
shut up you feel alive
go get go check in somewhere jesus
christ who wants to help you
yeah that's gross it's gross and he
doesn't want to like again he wants to
be that guy everybody i think that's why
everybody hates him
because he wants to be that guy he we
all know a guy in this at this age range
that acts like this and they're like
it's just expected of them man i'm just
crazy i'm out there man and it's like no
you just refuse to take any personal
responsibility and get help there's
plenty of people like
because we've all known people in our
lives that had like
a real bad phase a struggle they went
through something
but they weren't like
this brazen about it like yeah man this
is what i do man just what works for me
man you're like no it's not [ __ ]
working for you this guy just
some some other guys in life just
embrace the whole no this is what i am a
piece of [ __ ]
and i'm never gonna
i'm never gonna try to
treat people better or or make myself
more responsible or consider it no man
this is what i am hey pete you want to
be a rock star sure i got one for you to
be how about be chester bennington
do a world of favorite why don't you do
that why don't you i'll give you some
other rock stars kurt cobain
huh
why don't you do that huh why don't you
be that
scott wylan
uh hc frick
more like scott wilen out am i right you
should do that joe hc frank jim brewer
wasn't funny but he gave a hundred and
ten percent i got it especially when he
was good boy you know what though i'll
say this you know i know a lot of people
say this is like a cop output
jim brewer on the radio
was amazing great story jim brewer
telling a story and talking to you like
a person is really good but you have to
stand up man
the rock bands what was that so um
pete much like the knicks jersey you're
wearing
you are destined to fail my friend great
[ __ ] freeze frame look at that yeah
exactly i was leaving it up for a while
to hopefully get the thumbnail
that's my thumbnail ah that's right that
should have a black dot-com logo on it
because you can see the profile of
charlemagne right now it really shows
can somebody make this a black dot-com
here i'll full screen it for you guys
real quick screenshot that bad boy there
you go that's a perfect black dot-com
watermark